it's the beginning of yet another week
so I give you my review of the final
chapter of the Star Wars trilogy Return
of the Jedi right so Return of the Jedi
is the conclusion of the Star Wars
trilogy so this has to be good it is
good but it does have some give-and-take
so Return of the Jedi starts out on
Tatooine in Jabba's palace because
before you take out the Empire you got
to get your pal back the Jabba's palace
segments actually really cool I like it
you see Jabba the Hutt for the first
time because he was not in the original
Star Wars because he just wasn't he's
this big sluggish slob you know just
eats all day long it's just a party all
the time in Jabba's palace even in your
new with 80s music mirror they change
the song for the special edition which I
actually hate it more I'm just saying
when you make a cartoon dancing sequence
with like three cgi characters one's a
little furry thing that looks like a
Tribble with a mouth that goes dead and
it still sounds like 80s music you might
as well have just left it the 80s music
that you had before in any case you see
Han Solo still on the wall and this
bounty hunter goes up to Han Solo and
thaws him out you're like why'd that
person do that that's weird
oh it's Leia that's a pretty clever
chick right there but the victory is
short-lived before Jabba the Hutt
captures her and dresses are down in
Slave Leia outfit this was pre percoset
Ben she was hot in walks Luke Skywalker
Luke is like a completely different
person at this point he's not whiny he's
not bratty he's not hasty he's like this
Jedi who's really smart now and I must
speak with Jabba he has a cloak so he
looks like the Emperor what I think is
interesting is when Luke Skywalker's
negotiating with JA by Java flipped some
[ __ ] he's like no I'm not giving you
your friends and the Luke Skywalker just
does the force thing and gets a blaster
and tries to shoot him in the face so a
Jedi tried to shoot first take that
George Lucas then they get taken to the
Sarlacc pit the [ __ ] in the sand
which is funny because with the special
edition it's not one of those Piranha
Plants that comes out of the pipes and
Mario Brothers I hate that thing too but
I like this bar cause Luke gets his
lightsaber and he throws down he doesn't
even have grace for more choreography or
anything like that when people are
fighting Darth Maul on the prequels no
he just takes this thing he's explaining
it like a bat and guys are getting hit
they're getting trashed and they're
dying because Luke Skywalker is a
veteran in the force now I guess and
then comes the phrase that I've used in
a few of my reviews being Boba Fett it
being Boba Fett it is when someone's
really cool
character and they just get taken out
like that and a stupidest way possible
Han turns around accidentally hits Boba
Fett's backpack he goes shooting across
the screen and lands into the Sarlacc
pit he's dead now and I know in the
extended Laura apparently they said well
he's not dead well I don't read those to
me all I have is the movies and Boba
Fett died in the dumbest way possible
and after this Luke is talking with Yoda
it was just today I was watching Return
of the Jedi and I was like oh that's who
Yoda looks like he looks like mr. Miyagi
one of the sad parts of Return of the
Jedi
Yoda does die and his dying words to
Luke are there is another Skywalker you
find out that is Princess Leia yeah
they're brother and sister
when he tells her he's like do you
remember your mother your real mother
she's like oh yeah just a little bit she
died when I was very young just want
Luke to be like like how young about
thirty seconds were you thirty seconds
old when she died how do you remember
that you weirdo I don't remember that
and I'm mister force Jedi reason 3760 to
George Lucas screwed [ __ ] up at the
prequels and in terms of the Empire in
this movie the Empire has apparently
amassed the resources to reconstruct the
Death Star that's right the first Death
Star took about 20 years to construct
this was like six work for the common
man supported by the Empire but yes
screw that noise we're still going to
blow that [ __ ] up however with the
emperor on the Death Star the rebellion
has no choice this is their time to
strike and they're going to take this
[ __ ] down and so they go down to the
forest moon of Endor to take out the
shield generator that's you know pretty
much protecting the Death Star and then
comes the thing in Return of the Jedi I
hate oh alright
odds are you've asked a girl hey do you
like Star Wars and her response was well
I like the one with the little fuzzy
bears she's talking about the Ewoks I
hate these things I hate them so much
why do I hate them it's actually here it
is
the Ewoks represent the first time
George Lucas was like hey I'm going to
create something and I'm going to do it
not for what's best for the story and
the plot of the movie but I'm going to
do it for merchandising so I can make a
couple of crappy kids movies after this
kids will like the Ewoks II walked oiz
will sell like hotcakes that's why the
Ewoks came to be I'm just saying when
the emperor says Oh an entire Legion of
my best troops are on that moon and they
get taken out by Ewoks that's stupid I
would rather have wookies I could
probably buy that but no up in this
whole Throwdown down in the forest moon
of Endor sticks and rocks getting hit
against stormtrooper armor that takes
him out I mean the entire forest moon of
Endor thing isn't all stupid yeah
pretty cool speeder bike scene that's
alright however Luke goes on a cyclist
he's like Vader's my father there is
still good in him I have felt it I got
to change him back to the good side if
for nothing else I get to say that to
the Emperor and when the emperor is
taunting Luke it's like the coolest
thing ever I love it the Emperor is just
a wordsmith when he's all like strike me
down in your journey towards the dark
side will be complete and Luke just like
yep it takes his lightsaber and tries to
crack the Emperor right over the chest
Vader blocks I mean then we have a fight
it was really cool seeing Luke be like
yeah I think the ends will justify the
means here alright you're dead not quite
a Boy Scout that's what I'm talking
about Luke is probably the only Jedi in
the history of the Star Wars movies that
we actually relate to because there's a
normal person who just happens to be a
badass with the lightsaber now and this
is why I can look past a little teddy
bears that are fighting down on the
forest moon of Endor that I'd rather
forget because the conflict between Luke
Vader and the Emperor is just really
cool but it's more than just lightsaber
fighting you know it's a conflict Luke's
like I'm trying to bring you back to the
good side and the Emperor's over here
taunting him use your aggressive
feelings boy it's a tough fight for Luke
at this point then Vader throws his
lightsaber Luke Falls and it's like he
disappears like no one knows where he
went
Vader didn't see where Luke went the
emperor didn't see where Luke win you
gotta think Vader might have some
night-vision goggles in that mask or so
there's gotta be some special thing
going on with it but it doesn't matter
because this is a really cool moment in
the Star Wars trilogy Luke is sitting in
the dark Vader's just taunting him
Luke's got half his face in the shadow
the other half and the lights totally
symbolic and totally awesome meanwhile
Vader finds out that he has a sister and
then he says if you will not turn to the
dark side then perhaps she will Luke
snaps just whips out his lightsaber
never and just starts wailing away on
Vader the cool thing about this there's
no grace or form to it again no
choreography
he's just wailing away on Vader and you
can see the way Vader's backing up he's
like oh [ __ ] I didn't is that that but
Luke goes ballistic and just slices off
Vader's hand payback is a [ __ ] and he's
got him at Point at a point when Luke
has Vader on the ground at mercy the
Emperor starts talking he's like you
know hate has made you powerful fulfill
your destiny and take your father's
place at my side and the kind of snaps
out of it he's like oh man he looks at
his hand he notices he has a robot hand
just like later he notices he's becoming
just like Darth Vader he retracts his
lightsaber and he throws and he's like
I'll never turn
the dark side if the emperor had just
not said anything you just let Luke do
his thing I think Luke might have
actually killed Vader but because the
Emperor just had to open his mouth it's
snapped Luke out of it and that's why
the Emperor failed
truly illustrating that silence is
golden then we see something we've never
seen before I mean you know before this
it was all like forced jokes and reading
minds we never seen someone throw
lightning out of their hands the Emperor
does he's like he would be destroyed he
starts shooting lightning at Luke you're
like huh
how do you fight that I remember when I
was a kid I was like I don't care what
Yetta says I've never seen the lights
I'd do that [ __ ] and he's really cooking
Luke too he's letting him have it he
wants him to suffer before he kills him
and this is one of the greatest moments
ever I said that a lot in Star Wars
reviews but I'm just saying it is when
he's cooking Luke Skywalker you see the
way the camera pans up to Vader you can
see Vader's conflicted about this he's
really he's looking back to the Emperor
back to Luke and when the Emperor is
getting his jollies frying Luke Vader
looks at Luke back to the Emperor and he
just picks the Emperor up and just hauls
his ass over that power generator
whatever it is what doesn't matter he
falls he screams he blows up he dies and
that is the part in the blu-ray that
Lucas changed Star Wars for the worst
this was it this one broke my back a lot
of the other ones did too but this is
the time and I was like I'm not buying
these blu-rays I can't in the blu-ray
version when the Emperor's frightened
Luke and Vader is looking back and forth
between him you hear Vader go No then
when he picks him up his own uh you
can't do that [ __ ] the best part about
that scene in Star Wars is that without
saying a word you can tell he even has a
mask on you cannot see Vader's facial
expression but from the tone and the
camerawork alone you can tell that
Vader's conflicted about this moment you
know what he's going to do yours rooting
for me like dude come on do it no words
spoken it just happens and it's perfect
why did he have to yell no in the same
way he yelled no in Episode three that
never happened but if it did he would
have yelled no in a really stupid ass
way and it so happens when Vader took
out the Emperor the lightening shorted
everything out in his suit and now he's
going to suffocate and die so Luke get
some face time with him when he peels
his mask back reveals questi old white
boy inside I was kind of thought he
looks like Humpty Dumpty but it's really
interesting you see him you're like yeah
you did all that damage that's that's
what that's interesting to me in any
case this is the scene where Vader dies
he dies actually a hero he'd
a good guy it's really sad when you
think about it you're like Vader died
and so Luke gets out of there the Death
Star blows up the Emperor's dead and
they're all happy they're all
celebrating with that one song yab yab
yab yab although if you look at the
whole yup-yup song that takes place on
Endor I guess that would be the
celebration they would get it would just
kind of be a local celebration because
they're like we don't know how the rest
of the galaxy is dealing with this but
we're happy and we're here with the
Bears so I guess we're going to hang out
and have a barbecue missing the yep you
have some in this special edition he
showed all the other planets celebrating
so I do like that it showed how everyone
else reacted to the Emperor getting
toasted originally it showed the spirits
of Yoda and obi-wan Kenobi and then this
other guy appears he's his older guy
you've never seen him before it takes
you a second before you're like who's
that oh my gosh that's Darth Vader it's
great it's awesome I love seeing that it
just makes sense to me why would they
have young Vader there but in the DVD
release he had to change it up again he
has now superimposed Hayden Christensen
the one who played young Anakin
Skywalker there why I have no good idea
because the kids who bought the toys and
play the video games will recognize him
I guess who's gonna recognize the old
guy who played Vader for like two
seconds before he died it's stupid it's
dumb it makes not why why does he get a
young body
Lucas's reasoning was like well that's
how old Vader was last time he was good
no last time he was good was when he
died in the Death Star when he picked
the Emperor up and threw his ass over
that thing and blew him up if that's the
logic he died good then he should be the
older guy when he's a spirit in any case
our trilogy about conflict and family
and sacrifice and loyalty good versus
evil the coming-of-age story betrayal
friendship and everything that comes
with it comes to an end with Return of
the Jedi
I love Return of the Jedi I hate the
Ewoks a lot but I still cannot skip out
on giving this movie's awesome tacular
because Return of the Jedi ultimately -
the stupid
Ewoks which I can get over is awesome
tacular
it's that final conflict man that Luke
Emperor Darth Vader situation that
brings it up to an awesome tacular
that's what makes me forget about the
little stupid fuzzy bears however I have
met people who are like I want to say
that Return of the Jedi is a great movie
but it's only a good movie because I
cannot get past the little Ewok and I
can never argue them I'm always like I
understand I draw the line at a lot of
other stupid [ __ ] Lucas has done he
walks being the prelude the genesis of
his stupid ideas so the star wars
trilogy Return of the Jedi what's your
favorite part whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more